welcome back to part 2 of our Ingraham
angle exclusive with Donald Rumsfeld I
asked him why the bushes seemed to have
such a problem with him and the many
foreign policy challenges facing
President Trump under North Korea
because obviously this continues to be
such a difficult problem seemingly
intractable problem for the United
States we seem to be kind of relying a
lot on China and you back I was going
back and Donald Rumsfeld warning China
over military expansion in October of
2005 you are on the tiniest thing to
quote me and way way back and you were
concerned about the build-up of their
military and now China's flying missions
right near our joint missions with South
Korea this week coming very close to
where we were kind of sending a message
don't provoke North Korea what about
China what do we do with China right now
in this situation that's a new period
China's a major power and certainly in
that part of the world and it strikes me
that President Trump is focusing on the
right thing to be interested in the
behavior on the part of the North
Koreans and I don't doubt for a minute
but that his effort to engage China on
that subject is the right thing to do
choices
exactly China is a reality it's very
active in the South China Sea I think
the world is probably what's a bigger
threat to us I'll say Russia or China
who's a bigger threat to the United
States Russia or China
I suppose that answer the question by
saying it depends on who's in the saddle
in those countries and which one is more
likely to make a mistake because it's
it's not in either of those countries
interest to engage us militarily and it
would only happen through an error and
my personal view is that the fact that
Trump I don't know President Trump I've
never met him but but I that I can
recall but I I certainly think that he
his demeanor in the presidency is a
turrent for those countries because he
seems he seems like because from the hip
kind of thing he's not he's not tucked
in and and worried and cautious he's
he's a bold leader and he speaks his
mind and it seems to me that that that
people sitting in the Kremlin and then
in Beijing seeing that are probably
respectful of the fact that they are
that it's not in their interest to
engage in things that are
disadvantageous to the United States
President Obama was over traveling in
India and other countries last week and
he talked about dangerous currents of
populism on the but he said I'm like he
got through in the left and right in
that we have a leadership vacuum in the
United States when it comes to issues
like climate change do you think it's a
wise to have a former president of the
United States on the global scene
not-so-veiled criticism of the current
president wise I don't know that I'd use
the word wise or unwise it's it's
unfortunate most people when they're
overseas tend to be more supportive of
our country and more critical of our
country when they're here at home and
and that's free play and free speech and
and one has to respect everyone's right
to be critical but most people do their
criticism at home rather than abroad the
bushes over the years have taken some
swipes at you HW and W George HW Bush
Bush 41 said that he you know one point
or another said that you and Cheney were
basically pushing us into the Iraq war
and double you've made a comment and a
book that was published this month he
said the fact that there was any doubt
in anyone's mind about who the president
was blows my mind Cheney and Rumsfeld
didn't make one blanking decision yeah
there's he's right I think that that his
father who's getting up in years
made some comments about Cheney and
Rumsfeld fair enough he's always felt
competitive and I think to both of us
and so I doesn't surprise me but George
W Bush who was president was the decider
he was the president United States
Cheney wasn't I wasn't and and he's
exactly correct in his statement and it
was kind of a I think stiffing arm his
father a bit by saying that and I think
it would be wrong to have said anything
else
obviously he's talking about big
decisions and and he was the president
and he made those big decisions Cheney
didn't and Rumsfeld didn't and obviously
Cheney gave advice to the president as
vice president and I made an awful lot
of decisions relating to the Defense
Department but not presidential level
decisions you keep in touch with George
W Bush I've summed not a lot but I've
seen him and then what's a relationship
like it's good it's fine he's a
thoughtful person and I thought he was a
good president I think the country was
lucky he was there on 9/11 and he he's
doing some good things for the military
now I sure is but so dhw comments from
that Meacham biography back in 2015 we
said I don't like what Rumsfeld did and
I think it hurt the president having his
iron ass view of everything I've never
been that close to him anyway there's a
lack of humility a lack of seeing what
the other guy thanks
he's more kick ass and take names take
numbers I think he paid a price for that
Rumsfeld was an arrogant fellow and
self-assured swagger interesting well he
came into the Congress and basically
wanted to be President he can't I was in
Congress when he arrived and he comes in
and he barely was a congressman he was
constantly running for president and he
wanted to be President and he got it he
made it by becoming Reagan's vice
president and he was very ambitious and
and he felt competitive with me during
that period I tried to run for president
at one point obviously didn't become
president but but that doesn't surprise
me a bit I don't you know I don't get up
and say things like that about other
people myself but we surprised he didn't
vote for Trump and neither did george w
i didn't know that but i've read
somebody told me they read that i'm not
surprised about a herbert walker bush
and nothing surprises me on wi did he
say he didn't vote he didn't vote for
anyone apparently none of the above he
didn't vote for hillary I bet no no I
voted for Trump and I wouldn't have
voted for Hillary and I get up in the
morning and say to myself I think the
country is better off today then if we
had Hillary in the presidency